hi Katie hi Bryan now we're like zoom
buddies at this point I feel yeah oh
it's so funny well it is so good to see
you some very exciting news that we will
talk about a little bit later but I just
want to say congratulations on the
engagement first of all thank you so
much I appreciate it but something else
to celebrate season two of holy moly
comes out Thursday
right yes Thursday can you believe that
on ABC
holy moly has a really tender place in
my heart because it's it's it's nice to
relive what we all love doing which is
laughing playing outside connecting
getting crazy acting a fool like nobody
else is watching laughing at each other
and making it permissible to yeah
holy moly is is my favorite getaway last
season if you didn't catch it it was
America's favorite show when it came to
miniature golf extreme sports and mayhem
and so this year it's even crazier we
have a huge jackpot of $250,000 - the
greatest golfer / athlete / gymnast
/ can laugh themselves yes we have so
many fun celebrities that stop by and
got into the festivities I didn't know
that this many celebrities actually
golfed in this way I was gonna ask you
about any special cameos the greatest
one of them all you know is our EP which
is Steph Curry and we have you know I
can't tell you because it's a surprise
but just stand back and get ready
because you are going to be so surprised
at these celebrities not only golf but
having this type of sense of humor and
this type of daredevil ability it's
pretty cool when I think of Steph Curry
I think of the NBA
are we talking athletes people type of
celebrity you can think of okay
well I'm so excited to watch I'm also
like I said very excited about eat your
engagement watching the video that you
posted made me a little bit emotional
just because of how thoughtful he was
was there a part that you were blown
away by was there a part that made you
extra emotional about that
the main king that really touched me was
the intention I'm really learning during
this quarantine that it's the very
little things that matter most it's the
intention in people's actions for
something like an engagement especially
when he could have had such a beautiful
have you know a beautiful experience of
doing it in Vietnam but just doing it
here that's the symbolism to quarantine
I think for all of us and especially for
our marriage but just for everybody is
that nothing should stop you living your
life nothing when it comes to your goals
your dreams your relationships your your
closure and things your bonding with
yourself all of that should persevere
even greater now that we have the
quarantine and that's that's what I'm
most proud about when it comes to the
symbolism of that engagement are there
three wedding must-have throw in that
special day comes God I'm not even in
that mode so I can't really think on
that level um
how about if I just give you one having
a peace of mind is everything and
everything oh yeah you guys want to hit
like did you want to have a big wedding
before this pandemic sort of started was
it did you always want to go sort of
more intimate you know when it honestly
right now that that's not on the top of
our list
like we're so happy to be able to
celebrate an engagement right now I feel
like we've got work to do I feel the
quarantine is bringing a lot yeah it's
bringing a lot of people closer together
J and I I'm really thankful for the
quarantine because we actually just we
leaned in more to each other and we're
very conscientious of checking in with
each other and having really in-depth
conversations with the things that we're
unhappy about with the state of affairs
and and what we can be doing more in in
one another's lives so for us it's been
therapeutic and helpful really been
thankful for the quarantine I love that
and I love that you called him your soul
mate that made my heart happy oh it
sounds in person
I never recognized what a soul mate was
until I found Mike he had assembled a
video with my mom my dad his dad and
every single person that was supposed to
be on this trip to Vietnam
nothing wrong with head your soulmate
yes there was a video message from all
of your loved ones actually but there
was one that stood out to me and it was
from his dad who said don't wait to walk
down the aisle what is it like wedding
planning in foreign team is there a
timeline that you're looking at you know
we talk about it a lot but at this
moment what we're really focused on is
the state of affairs just just what's
going on when it comes to our economy
our society our communities I know for J
it's it's it's heartbreaking to hear the
struggle of you know the black in the
brown community not being able to just
be able to get to just a place where you
can feel like you've taken a breath and
for me I I'm torn
just reading headline after headline
with all these situations of racism
happening on so many different levels
and the one thing I just hope for both
of us the one thing that that is most
important to us to spread the message of
right now is to really recognize one
another as brothers and sisters right
really recognize that we are all one of
the same right now and we can't expect
or lean on our authorities or leaders to
make the best decisions right now we
only have each other to put an end to
racism and have these discussions in our
households and those are the kinds of
things that we're talking about right
now to be honest with you you you did
penned this really powerful essay about
that because I mean you were getting
hate on your Instagram which I didn't
even know about until I read this thing
that you wrote do you feel like that
made a difference and like what does
that feel like for you and and sort of
use this platform to tell us like how
everyone can do better the number one
thing I think all of us should be doing
is standing up for one another and I'm
talking to not only people of different
races of white people's doing it for
brown people brown people doing it for
black people but reinterpretations
Asians doing it for black like everybody
but it's also take an active step in in
and start to be more mindful about how
you think when even if you see a
headline because it's all
for Instagram right whether words
whether it's Brianna Taylor or it's
Ahmad Audrey or it's gonna be another
name tomorrow if you can just scroll
past it that's already the problem you
need to talk about it in your household
you need to have the conversation with
your kids it needs to be something that
we all recognize is is wrong and is
damaging to us and actually take action
against it so that's that's the one big
hope that I have for everybody to do I
don't know if you saw I mean I'm sure if
you've been reading the news you saw but
there was the former Bachelorette Hannah
Brown did you see this No so she was
singing she was rapping a song and she
used the n-word which should never be
condoned in my opinion ever yeah getting
some backlash about that and now there's
people sort of speaking out about what
she did and I guess she issued an
apology do you have anything to say
about something like that even I just
personally this is just for my own
feeling like that word there's so much
hey yeah there's a history of hate but
there's also just such a dark like such
a dark oppression that comes with that
word that still has not changed today
that word still holds a lot of pain not
only for the black community but just
everybody who was an American and
everybody who understands where that
word came from what it was used to mean
so I think that that reward should be
refrained from being used period but
especially if it's not your experience
to talk about we need to be more mindful
yes be more mindful about your actions
and and that's why I went back to the
word intentions what is your intention
when you're about to wrap a song like
what is your intention with the words
that you choose to use if it what is the
intention of the song itself when it was
written you know you have to think about
you have to start being responsible and
and if you notice right now during this
quarantine the number one thing that
we're learning can do so much damage is
not taking responsibility for your
actions or your leadership or lack
thereof
so it's really on it's on us as parents
as citizens it's our moral duty to just
do better and be stronger as a community
because we want America to sound and
look the way it's supposed to and right
now we're not doing a great job of it
and that I put that all on us as
individuals
[Music]